und jetzt sage ich schon mal an alle die
jetzt denken wow das ist krass was ist
das für ein thema schaltet bitte weg
hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde wird
spielen die ich glaube wir wollten
halten zu spielen habe ich mir überlegt
und zwar habe ich ja schon in den
letzten galaxy folgen okay so schon
stückchen länger her mal gesagt dass ich
mit euch über ein thema quatschen wollte
was mich so ein bisschen als ich das
darüber erfahren hab so ein bisschen
schockiert
das heißt ein bisschen es hat mich
extrem schockiert das war richtig
richtig krass wir gehen jetzt erst mal
ganz kurz hier in block 3
also ich nenne es einfach immer noch
halten zieht weil es ist für mich ein
sieg und wir suchen sondern man direkt
ins hand das team gehen weiß ich jetzt
schon bock ins hand hat ihm da kann man
so ein paar leute ja ich bin in der ich
bin platz drei von drei hinter schlange
und wir nehmen welchen unternehmen wir
keine user radar hand erklärt ich bin
haider haider haider haider ich habe
mich doch für hunter als bin ich ja egal
ich bin dann wohl wenig hunter moment
bin ich einem schiff werde ich gar nicht
auf welcher mit map wir sind ich glaube
das ist das schiff oder die am meisten
oder schiff oder nicht raus ich bin doch
ein halter so klick blog change vor
wir machen uns einfach mal ne
zusammenspiel muss man sich zu viel
bewegen
wir verwandeln uns einfach mal in und
kuchen es mal so ich wollte nämlich mit
euch über das shadow web reden das
shadow web ist erstmal ich packe euch
einen link in die beschreibung da könnt
ihr euch eine story angucken über das
web
ich hab da noch gar nicht mehr oder acht
ich kann das noch gar nicht benutzen
moment als 21 ich kann das allgemein
dann kann ich doch jetzt geht's jetzt
informieren
das web auf fakt das ist ja offen hier
ja doch was ist sogar die map mit dem
schiff die haben die kinder das mit dem
schiff das hab ich hab' ich hab' ich war
mal ganz von anfang an
während ich abitur gemacht habe habe ich
verpasst ich blocke habe ich mit dem
freund gelernt und er hat mir so ein
link geschickt
besonders story denn es war mitternacht
und wenn man fürs abitur lernt weiß man
tagsüber ist man am schlafen und nachts
lernt man das ist irgendwie immer so
dass wir bei all meinen freunden aus als
wären es alle geschafft jetzt werden
oder unser aber jetzt aber das war schon
krass
naja jedenfalls reichen haider sieger
hunter und wir waren
er hat mir das geschickt so gegen
mitternacht und 1 er ließ das besser
nicht mehr jetzt und gerade wenn euch
jemand schreibt oder auch wenn denn
einem gesagt wird denken nicht an den
elefanten dann linke jetzt grad an einen
elefanten und er schreibt mir ist es
nicht doch ich lese ich also habe ich
davor gesetzt hat mir diese geschichte
durchgelesen und man muss schon ein
bisschen englisch können dafür dass man
was ein bisschen versteht
jedenfalls ich lese mir diese geschichte
durch und ich spiele jetzt mal also das
heißt bayern das ist eine geschichte die
hat keine fünf minuten durchlesen könnt
ihr euch ja selbst auch mal durch lese
ich sag's euch jetzt auf jeden fall mal
für alle die die das nicht durchgehen
soll aber es ist schon zum texte
scrollen muss
dass so ein typ der arbeitet an der
tankstelle und es geht ich etikett der
paysafecard com wertkarten kennt liegen
sie falsch und wenn ihr minecraft habt
dann müsst ihr das irgendwie auch mit
paysafecard gekauft haben oder geht es
mit peter liebers gar nicht oder mit
steam spiele das sind so karten da gibt
man jemanden 10 euro quasi das der
geringste betrag an der tankstelle geht
das quasi immer gibt's zudem 10 euro ich
hätte gerne zehn euro paysafecard dann
kriegst du so einen code mit diesem code
man kann ich einfach sagen zehn euro
putzen computer rein sondern als gegner
mit sondern paysafecard und davon gibt
es auch so andere karten ich weiß nicht
mehr wie die hießen das ist schon ein
monat her seitdem ich die story gelesen
habe jedenfalls gibt es auch so andere
karten die mit paysafecard inhalten
sondern solche coupons für 100 euro oder
500 euro so ein bisschen höhere beträge
die geht man die gibt's eigentlich immer
für porno sachen steht glaube ich in dem
text ich weiß nicht ich kenne mich damit
nicht aus
und da dieser dieser der protagonist in
dieser story also die hauptperson meint
dann halt so der citadel arbeitet an der
tankstelle und sieht dann immer so einen
typen der so jede woche mal ankommt also
ich weiss nicht genau das jetzt stimmt
mit jeder woche es kann auch sein dass
in dem text steht alle zwei tage oder
jede jeden tag oder allem jeden einmal
ein monat oder so ich sag jetzt einfach
mal so ein bisschen freier damit ihr das
so ein bisschen kapiert was kapiert ist
es wenn ich das café erkläre ich mich
einfach mal ein bisschen mehr punkte und
der kommt halt immer mal sein so öfters
da an und sonntag kam dann immer mal so
ein typ und hat sich dann immer mal für
100 euro da mal 50 euro für 500 euro
diese ganzen beträge geholt diese
coupons sage ich mal und ist dann quasi
damit dann immer abgeholt einmal hat an
der protagonistin dann gefragt hey wieso
holst du dir die ganze sache eigentlich
und wofür weil er dachte immer dass es
für porno wer aber irgendwie konnte der
den nicht so richtig in der porno szene
zuordnen
und da meinte der so willst du wirklich
willst du bla bla bla und dann hat er
den zettel geschrieben oder so oder
erzieher mündlich gesagt ich weiß nicht
mehr so genau
ich mach das mal so ein bisschen auf
meine art und weise dass das ganze für
etwas ist was der web ist alles mögliche
und jetzt komme ich noch zum shadow gab
das ist quasi etwas das gibt es wirklich
das shadow web gibt es wirklich das ist
nicht fiktiv die ganze story ist
wirklich mal geschehen vielleicht nicht
direkt so auf die art und weise aber auf
jeden fall so ein bisschen es hat auf
jeden fall waren kennen und das ist
etwas wo alles da stattfindet was nicht
im normalen internet legal wäre also
drogenverkauf leichenteile verkauf
natürlich auch der kauf dieser sachen
kauf und verkauf der handel einfach auch
so sachen wie waffen bomben anleitungen
wie man sich umbringt so was alles was
man vielleicht findet man sowas mit ich
weiß nicht oder so was wie ein strick
oder keine ahnung der zeitbombe oder
auch einfach solche sachen wie
nekrophilie nekrophilie heißt es nico
viele ich glaube schon
die trophy ist der geschlechtsakt mit
gleichen also wenn man leiche befriedigt
naja egal und jetzt sage ich schon mal
an alle die jetzt denken wow das ist
krass was ist das für ein thema schaltet
bitte weg also ich will nicht dass
irgendwer ich weiß es ihr junger seite
und ich will nicht dass irgendwer von
euch irgendwie zu den eltern geht und
sagt hey komm mal was der für ne sch eis
erzählt ich möchte halt wirklich nur
euch das mal näher bringen dass das
internet wirklich gefährlich sein kann
noch 7 40 sekunden und mich findet die
recht keiner drin da komme ich gerade
daran wer mir drin neben mir der
verräter fakt der sieht michael ich
nicht ehrlich nicht gott wenn ich zwei
sogleich blöcken da sehen wir den wegen
frack jedenfalls gibt es das alles da so
richtig illegale sachen einfach
untersteller hat gibt es wirklich und er
dieser protagonist hat an diesen
zettelchen bekommen wo dann drauf steht
so und so kommst du ins shadow web rhein
bleibe aber bleibt weil das ist nicht
einfach dass man bei google eingibt
shadow web und dann ist also eine
website und dass man darauf wandern ist
alles schwarz
dann kann man in sachen kaufen und
leichenteile und waffen das ein bisschen
easy es geht darum total verschlüsselte
codes und wir haben gewonnen und ich
weiß auch nicht mehr ganz genau wie die
jetzt rein gekommen dass ich sag mal
einfach das ist irgendwie auch das ist
eine komische animation
ich dachte einfach dass also ich stelle
es mir so vor indes tories ich weiß
nicht mehr genau wie es in der story
gemachtes vorgestellt wurde aber ich
würde mal so grob tippen das ist
irgendwie dass man den zugriff
ich weiß es wirklich nicht ich würde mal
so tippen dass man den zugriff irgendwie
bekommt durch durch ich weiß nicht dass
man auf der website geht diesen code
kopiert den woanders einfügt den code
dementsprechend verändert dann noch muss
man noch im geld bezahlen und dann noch
seine kontonummer angeben oder noch da
wieder an kopieren und dann da wieder
einfügen tag kopieren und einfügen und
alles und dann daran entschlüsselten
code rauskriegen also irgendwie wenn man
sich irgendwo hinter schnallt wenn man
irgendwo denkt okay ich will da
unbedingt rein dann kommt man da auch
rein das ist immer so das ist eigentlich
bei allem so wenn man irgendwas an
kommen wir dann kommt man auch an
ich empfehle es euch nicht ich will das
selber nicht machen
jedenfalls ich komme jetzt auf den punkt
diese person viel haben sie jetzt die
story durch gelesen weil ich schon viel
länger gelagert habe ich mag das immer
so dass ganze ausführlich zu erklären
und ein bisschen abseits von der story
und naja jedenfalls ist dieser typ dann
in diese starren reingekommen und hat
dann gesehen dass da waffen waren da
lang wurden leichenteile verkauft da
waren bomben anleitungen wie die gebaut
werden und alles und nimmt auch eine auf
ich verstehe jetzt einfach mal aus
münchen
sie werden immer direkt angegriffen da
denkt jeder immer kann ich nicht einfach
hier eine melone
nein hier ja ok es müssen auffällig noch
egal jedenfalls ist denn diese shadowrun
rein gekommen weil an da drin und hat
dann halt diese ganzen sachen angesehen
was ich schon gesagt habe und es dann
auf was ich werde hier noch nie hatte
weggedrückt wo soll ich denn sonst hin
aber ich hatte hier schon mal so ein
geiles versteckt dass es dahin das
gebäude da hinten drin weil ich im
moment nicht das irgendwie anders kommt
hier stand ich immer so dass eigentlich
ganz cool hier europäischen teile
das hat er dann halt alles gesehen und
dann war da auch eine seite wo
livestream stand und dann hatte sich das
live stream her dass köln nicht zu
stemmen ist darauf geklickt und da kann
man und das gibt es wirklich leute bitte
schaltet ab wenn ihr jetzt keine horror
geschichten hören wollt schon mal die
tür geht auf
ich immer noch hier hin alter das
wahrlich creepy jedenfalls hat er dann
diese leihstimmen seite entdeckt und
leute es gibt das gibt es wirklich lasst
euch das mal auf der zunge zergehen der
zunge zergehen vielleicht der falsche
ausdruck
da werden leute da sind dann zum
beispiel 40 viewer in diesem stream
erkennt vielleicht von kitsch und da
sieht man also zwei leute mit masken und
kettensägen und tennisschläger nach
tennis baseball schlägern und so ein
schwachsinn
und dann sieht man da eine person
gefesselt
bitte jetzt wegschalten wenn ihr keine
horror geschichte hören wollt und man
kann dadurch wo dieser typ in dieser
tankstelle diesem gutschein diesem
coupon gekauft hat für 100 200 500.000
10.000 euro kann man diesen leuten
diesen zwei leuten mit dem baseball
schlägern diesen gutschein diesen coupon
code senden und dementsprechend wie viel
geld das ist dementsprechend fügen sie
dieser person schaden hinzu das heißt
wenn man beispielsweise dahin schickt
zehn euro dann sagen die vielleicht ok
10 euro dafür haben wir der alm aufs
maul
wenn man dann sagt ok komm ich habe 500
euro und ich will dass ihr dieser person
die augen rausreißt und eure bilder
einräumt
dann machen die das das ist krass das
ist so unglaublich als ich diese
geschichte gesehen habe das ist so
unglaublich dieser junge hat das dann
gesehen wie dann irgendwie dieser frau
irgendwas angefügt wurde diese freund
geschrieben ein nein hört auf und er
wollte irgendwas tun
er sagt in dieser story wenn er
irgendwie es ist dies war er sagt in
dieser story wenn er irgendwie ist
geschafft hätte da den geld zu geben
hätte der den das doppelte an dem geld
gegeben dass dieser mann entgegen
gegeben hat der wollte dass der frau
etwas antun
und der hätte den das doppel gegeben
hätte dann gesagt wird auf lasst frei
aber er war halt nicht registriert und
er hat die ganze zeit geschrieben stapel
dabei hätte krieg galt kein geld und das
ist halt so immens kraft stellt euch vor
dass man da da da sind leute die
bezahlen you will be a scary movie so
afk ich stand er doch die ganz herum
wobei ich da den after takeoff ich ihr
noch als münchen rom
herr ackermann sieht mich stark ich
damals münchen zurück
die sie mich wirklich nicht große sache
okay wir sind wirklich blöd ich gehe
gleich der blogger zurück du arschloch
schnell nochmal mia und alles mögliche
machen
watson pixar töte mich kommen würde mich
töte mich ich hätte das mal ganz kurz zu
ende ich finde das einfach so krass
jedenfalls historie dann irgendwie noch
so zu ende dass dieser typ sieht dann
dass im chat steht jahr reist ihr die
augen aus oder irgendwie sowas oder
ihnen was anderes als in die nase raus
oder irgendeinen schwachsinn oder krank
die den kopf lief es mir genau das ist
schon länger her
ich würde es mir seitdem nicht mehr
durchgesetzt ich mich nicht getraut und
dann hat er sein bildschirm ausgemacht
und er hat ja die schreie von der frau
noch gehört und er hat einen bildschirm
ausgemacht hat sich denkt setzt
nachhinein und wollte dann hat dann
irgendwann die schreie weg und dachte
das spiel vorbei dass sein bild wieder
an macht dann hat einfach gesehen dass
die frau nicht mehr geschrien hat weil
die tod war da war die augen und da kam
das ganze blut draußen alles und die
geschichte ist einfach wahr
unterscheidung gibt es wirklich und
diese ganzen kranken sachen geht's
wirklich dass wir den 20 in deutschland
fabriziert ich hoffe dass es nicht
deutschen fabriziert und gedreht wird
sondern dann in irgendwelchen ländern
wie dem irak oder afghanistan oder so
solche länder halt und ich finde das
einfach nur so unglaublich krass ich
habe angst davor dass ich irgendwann mal
da reingeraten diese scheiß shadow web
oder dass ich davon irgendwann mal
träume weil seitdem ich diese geschichte
gesehen habe also dieser typ der diese
geschichte da geschrieben hat bei der
seite der hat gesagt dass er seitdem nur
noch bei steffen licht in seinem zimmer
an ist wenn er musik hört und alles
mögliche der ist der eimer reingegangen
und nie wieder
und das ist so krass und solche leute
die sowas machen und solche leute die
ich so was anschauen die gehören alle
einfach für immer weggesperrt
das ist unglaublich unglaublich niemand
sollte irgendwie mit solchen sachen
bestraft werden
das ist
ist einfach so irre das ist so
unglaublich krass erhält ist also ich
weiß nicht ob ich euch die story jetzt
gut näher bringen konnte das heißt näher
bringen das ist ich wollte halt wirklich
einfach nochmal darüber ein video machen
damit ich wollte euch einfach zeigen
dass das männchen
ich wollte euch damit wirklich einfach
zeigen dass das internet
oh mein gott wie muss es wohl für ihn
sein wenn jetzt elf sekunden verändert
noch getötet zehn sekunden vor ende
dieses opfer hat naja jedenfalls ich
wollte damit nur zeigen dass das ganze
internet nicht so cool ist wie man denkt
das ganze ist ein bisschen das alles
richtig krass die sache ist einfach ich
hab euch das nicht erzählt um euch angst
machen sondern wirklich einfach nur um
euch zu zeigen dass es solche krassen
seiten auch im internet gibt natürlich
heißt es nicht dass wenn ihr jetzt bei
google eingibt sherawat dass ihr direkt
darauf gelang tier sollte auch nicht
aufgenommen ich habe euch nur die
geschichte unten verlinkt es ist eine
krasse story sie ist echt und als ich
das gelesen habe ich mir gedacht alter
stellt euch vor ihr gelangt irgendwie
man in diesem job und ihr seht live wie
eine person die augen rausgerissen
werden ich meinem film ist das immer
noch anders als wenn das wirklich live
gerade passiert und sie ist dass diese
person lage stirbt das ist unglaublich
krasnaja darüber wollte ich einfach mal
mit euch reden ich habe glaube ich noch
nie so oft in einem video das wort
kasper verwendet tut mir leid dass ich
darüber als video gemacht habe aber ich
wollte wirklich einfach mal drüber reden
weil mich das krass beschäftigt seitdem
ich gelesen habe
und ja wenn euch sowas vielleicht
gefällt meine meinung über ein paar
dinge dann schreibt einen kommentar oder
zeigt sind einmalig und dann sehen wir
uns morgen wieder